if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman
unfortunately my first two stories today
are completely infuriating in a moment
in a few moments i'm going to talk about
the latest with the
spending infrastructure bill and just
the pathetic nature of what's happened
and we'll talk about whether at this
point progressives should just vote no
and do everything they can to kill the
bill we'll get to that but first i want
to start with the story of stephen
donziger the attorney who now is
surrendering to prison and it is an
absolutely insane story if you've not
been following the story
it is just like a perfect example of so
much of what is wrong with so many
different systems that we have in the
country so let's read the latest report
from reuters chevron foe danziger
surrenders after losing bid to avert
prison prison for the lawyer why well
let's look
disbarred lawyer stephen donziger who
was convicted of criminal contempt after
a decades-long legal battle with chevron
over rainforest pollution in ecuador
surrendered to authorities wednesday
after losing his bid to stay out of
prison
the second u.s circuit court of appeals
a couple days ago denied donziger's
request to delay his six-month prison
term or grant him bail as he challenges
his conviction and sentence his lawyer
ronald kooby said in court documents
wednesday he surrendered and is in
custody of the federal prison in danbury
connecticut quote it is sadly typical of
the degraded quality of justice in this
case that the only way mr donziger could
prove he was not a flight risk was to
show up and be imprisoned
donziger is appealing his july
conviction for criminal contempt and
october first sentencing to six months
prison by a federal judge in manhattan
now what is this all about
the contempt case stems from
post-judgment orders in a civil case in
which another manhattan judge in 2014
barred enforcement
in the u.s
of a 9.5 billion dollar judgment against
chevron that donziger won in an
ecuadorian court the judge said the
ecuadorian judgment had been secured
through bribery fraud and extortion
donziger who was disbarred in new york
last year was charged with contempt in
2019 for failing to turn over his
computer phones and other electronic
devices among other conduct
the new york resident has been in home
detention since august of 2019.
tuesday's second circuit order also
expedites donziger's appeal
so you have a situation here where
stephen donziger was fighting uh this
case in ecuador
against one of these big fossil fuel
companies and rainforest destruction
and then for what many assert and we'll
get to this in a moment are political
reasons and the power of corporations
this has all been completely flipped and
turned around on danziger who then said
guys i'm not giving you my stuff
and now he's been held in contempt and
now is being sentenced to six months for
that contempt now it's not just me
saying this sounds wrong
the united nations has ruled that the
entire stephen donzinger house arrest
violates international laws this is from
a few weeks ago close to a month ago the
un human rights body said
a former environmental lawyer's house
arrest on contempt charges was illegal
and called on the u.s to release him and
this provides some context stephen
donziger in the early 1990s sued texaco
on behalf of a group of ecuadorian
farmers and indigenous people alleging
major environmental harms by the energy
company
we've heard those stories many times
for decades these companies have known
the environmental damage that they were
doing through their fossil fuel
business an ecuadorian court ruled in
favor of the plaintiffs in 2011
and ordered chevron which had since
acquired texaco to pay nine and a half
billion dollars
then chevron countersued in the united
states
asking accusing the lawyer donziger of
bribery and witness tampering and then
judge louis kaplan in the u.s ruled in
chevron's favor and then donziger was
hit with contempt charges during the
appeals process when federal prosecutors
in the southern district of new york
declined to prosecute donziger on the
contempt charges the uh judge took the
unusual step of appointing private
attorneys instead
look at what is happening here rita
glavin one of the attorneys previously
worked for a firm
that chevron retained so
every reason to think
this is chevron wanting to get back at
an attorney that effectively went after
them for the environmental damage that
they did
u.s district judge found donziger guilty
of contempt in july
in the ruling uh in its ruling the un's
working group on arbitrary detention
called donziger's detention arbitrary
note noting the maximum penalty for
donziger's charges is actually six
months house arrest for two years
without sentencing for something where
you would only at the most serve six
months
this they wrote means mr donziger having
been under house arrest since august 6th
of 2019 has already served the maximum
possible penalty four times over in this
regard the working group recalls that
the human rights committee has argued if
the length of time that the defendant
has been detained reaches the length of
the longest sentence that could be
imposed for the crimes charged the
defendant should be released the working
group's five international jurists said
they were appalled by the case and said
the charges against and detention of
donziger appears to be retaliation for
his work as a legal representative of
indigenous communities as he refused to
disclose confidential correspondence
with his clients in a very high profile
case
against multinational business
enterprise
this is the worst of the worst of the
worst
um this is
very clearly
um retaliation by a company with massive
resources chevron
um against the guy
they allege that the settlement he
obtained of 9.5 billion dollars was done
through bribery but they've not proven
that understand that the allegation was
well they only got this settlement by
bribing people and fraud and so on and
so forth it's not been proven
they managed to make that case by
dumping legal fees upon legal fees to
create a problem for donziger they got
to a point where he was in a position of
saying turn over all these documents
related to your private dealings with
the plaintiffs he said no
now he's in contempt
there is a maximum sentence of six
months for that but he was held under
home confinement house arrest for two
years even though the if found guilty
the maximum possible sentence would have
been six months every aspect of this
stinks
it every effort was made to exhaust
every legal resource possible and i
believe it was yesterday or the day
before yes i think the day before it was
decided that yesterday he would turn
turn himself over to a connecticut um
prison or institution the institute of
prisons or the board of prisons or
whatever it's called in connecticut for
the six month sentence a lot of people
hadn't heard of this story
it is absolutely and completely bonkers
and uh
i don't think this is the end of it and
we're going to continue covering it
you all know
that i am in general a pragmatist
i am a sort of a real politic realist i
understand that change often comes in
small steps i don't want to let the
perfect become the enemy of the good
but
it may be time for progressives to kill
what is increasingly a gutted
infrastructure and spending bill because
there is almost nothing left in it
paid leave has now fallen out of the
democratic package in an urgent scramble
as described by cnn to secure
centrist democratic senator joe manchin
support
democrats are expected to scrap paid
family and medical leave
from their cornerstone economic and
climate package discarding one of the
central planks of joe biden's proposal
as they scramble to strike a deal with
holdout senators the planned survival
has been in question for several days
due to objections from joe manchin
biden's initial 12-week proposal of paid
leave was scaled back to four weeks to
try to get joe manchin's support that
was rejected
kirsten gillibrand tried to find a
compromise with manchin that didn't work
one of the people said prompting
democrats to push it out of the package
as they seek to scale back the
proposal's overall cost and programs to
meet mansion's demand
mansion made clear he would not move
when asked about the provision saying i
just can't do it and now as we're
filming this is about to happen joe
biden is expected to announce new social
spending and new social spending
framework to try to get every democrat
uh on board
the steps that we are now talking about
the increments that we are now talking
talking about are so small in terms of
what's left of this bill
that we may mostly have a pseudo slush
fund for some projects called
infrastructure
it'll be counted as a political win for
the centrist democrats it'll be counted
as a political win for republicans by
having been able to get all sorts of
stuff removed and it's going to be
barely anything and i am essentially
ready to say
you know it has some things in it that
makes sense
but the pic big picture is now so dire
it's so grim it's so pathetic
that it may be time to kill this bill
and say hey
you need us progressives for this too
and you're losing us
what has been removed so far my best
underst you've it's actually hard to
encapsulate everything that's been
removed so far
for a bunch of different reasons
including that there were different
bills that contained these things in
different negotiations
paid family leave seems to be gone or
will be gone soon a tuition-free
community college we already learned
days ago last week that's gone serious
climate regulations uh gone
expanded medicare eligibility gone
the vision hearing dental stuff that joe
biden talked about doesn't seem to be in
there prescription drug price controls
nope
universal child care plus making
permanent the tax credit gone
some kind of uh tax to target the very
very very richest americans not that not
going to be part of this bill apparently
either
so
listen i get it this this is very rare
that i say
actually
overall
because of a message that needs to be
sent nothing kind of makes more sense
than the scraps that are left rarely am
i at that point people who have been
following this show for a long time know
that
but it might be time with this bill
because uh this is going to
it'll count as something was done
when it's
two percent five percent not by dollar
value but in terms of the components
five percent of what was supposed to be
done and everybody but the left gets a
win republicans who want nothing done
well they almost get a win if this
passes because there's almost nothing
left of it centrists
get what they want because they've
managed to get all of the important
stuff or most of the important stuff out
of it or scale it down or whatever so i
am understanding you know i know other
shows pretend that the country is way
more left than it actually is and all
this different stuff i don't do that
here i feel like one of the things i try
to do is give you an honest and accurate
assessment of where is the country on a
lot of these issues the country is well
to the left of this bill there's no
doubt about it
um and what we have at this point
is
i don't know if the term pyrrhic victory
even applies because i don't know that
it's a victory even a pyrrhic one i want
to hear from you
is this
something that
any progressive that has the ability to
vote no should be voting no on because
it's become so
endlessly
pathetic let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at deepakman
we're going to take a quick break and we
have much more coming up for you today
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video we have a great subreddit
with nearly 35 000 of our viewers and
listeners subscribed for free you can
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i
a few interesting posts i spotted this
morning that i wanted to
discuss with you today one asks who can
win in 2024
david sir if you read this i'd like your
take despite it being too early i just
don't see biden running in 2024 he'll be
in his 80s and i think the next three
years will affect him far more than past
presidents harris may be the presumptive
nominee but she seems like a weak
candidate versus trump or desantis so
who would be a strong candidate in 2024
give five bucks a month to voter
register registration and outreach
programs today folks yeah this is um i
mean listen that's the analysis i made
about two months ago and i said we're
not yet ready to really talk about this
in detail because there are so many
unknowns who will be the republican
nominee is joe biden running for
re-election if not is kamal harris the
presumptive nominee but i've said before
most who wrote to me about it agreed
although a few people were were kind of
upset with me
um i see
if it's trump is the nominee in 2024
i see a
uh
uh of joe biden who will have been
attacked for four years and will be in
his 80s at that point as having a tough
time beating trump a second time
if it's not joe biden and it's kamala
harris
i see kamala harris who remains not
particularly popular today but there's
still a lot of time to go
i see kamala harris having a very tough
time against donald trump and then if
it's not trump and it's right now based
on polling ron desantis would be the the
most prominent name although
it's very early and this is why it's
tough to talk about it
i see ron desantis as a more competent
version of trump
who also has a totally plausible chance
of defeating someone like joe biden or
kamala harris being from florida
could help him with the state of florida
as well so i share the concern i don't
have answers i'm asking all the same
questions as this viewer i'm coming to
so far more or less the same conclusions
and i don't have the answers but maybe
people in the audience do another post i
spotted
asks
would you support something similar to a
vaccine passport but for antibodies
seems like this would be something the
left and right could compromise on but i
don't hear it being proposed from the
left i'm wondering if there are
arguments against it or if people are
even against it so i guess the question
is
if you could prove you have antibodies
to the coronavirus
should that count as being vaccinated
anywhere that you need to be vaccinated
if you have antibodies and there it's
it's very complicated there's two
primary problems i think
one is antibodies as measured by typical
blood tests measure only one type of
antibody and it's only one element of
immunity we still don't know how does
that number relate to your level of
protection
and ability to spread versus other types
of antibodies
and potential immunity so that's part
one
part two
there's less consistency about natural
antibodies and how long they last we
don't know if you're more sick
do you develop more antibodies when you
recover it all these types of things are
still being explored and so while
there's still variability in terms of
antibody development with vaccines
there's more known and it's more uniform
and more consistent than the decay
appears to be more predictable so i
think those are sort of like the two
main issues with saying we should have
an antibody passport just like we do a
vaccine passport also it's significantly
more expensive uh to test for antibodies
and um it also is much more involved
than simply to go you get a vaccine it's
free to the end user um who would pay
for you know different people have
different blood tests coverage through
insurance it it starts to get quite
quite complicated uh last thing
this is a very interesting article that
was posted
all of the discussion of the worker
shortage that we've been seeing
it's important to know
that since march of 2020 the us has
issued 1.2 million fewer visas to work
eligible foreigners so a lot of the
right wingers and by the way this report
is from the cato institute not exactly a
left-wing publication
one of the reasons right-wingers are
saying oh it's pete but edge edge's
fault it's joe biden's fault joe biden
is the grinch who stole
christmas because of supply chain issues
and all this stuff we already know the
supply chain issues were an issue in
2020 nobody was blaming transportation
secretary elaine chao back then nobody
was really blaming trump for that now
they're blaming biden and buddha judge
but the other issue is the u.s has
issued far fewer a work-eligible
foreigner visa since march of 2020
partially under the guise of the
pandemic yes
that is a big factor because the u.s
counts on that labor
and it's not being discussed
at all
and it should be that that is a
something right-wingers may not even
know about or may be glad about because
they say these people are stealing our
jobs etc well that's part of why we're
having these supply chain and labor
resource issues right now
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit
this is really really great stuff we're
going to look at now
remember trump's legal adviser john
eastman he's the lawyer who wrote the
infamous coup memo with various ideas as
to how maybe donald trump would be able
to steal the 2020 election
lauren windsor our friend from the
undercurrent has done it again and has
gotten
undercover video speaking to john
eastman essentially just bragging about
the entire memo his role and everything
let's take let's just go right into it
we've got video we've got audio the
video is subtitled let's just jump right
in and see this is amazing stuff
we're huge trump supporters
by the way this is lauren pretending to
be a trump supporter she's been doing
this now for months and she gets people
to put down their guard and say really
horrible and damning things actually at
january 6th oh yeah we saw yours
did i incite you to go down to the
capitol and riot you actually incited us
to become supporters of claremont oh
good very good very good because you
know the work that you're doing is so
critical to saving our democracy and it
was like
we couldn't she's so good at blowing
smoke on people's asses it's so funny i
support your work after that okay well
thank you very much that's very kind of
you so thank you you're you're really
doing the lord's work
you know
you heard me say it my old professor
said if you're not catching incoming
flack you're not over the target and my
god i must be directly over it because
yeah
i i don't think there's anybody catch as
much incoming flack maybe than other
than trump himself that i have the
biggest victory
but i read your memo and i thought it
was solid in all of its legal arguments
i just i was floored that
mike pence
didn't do anything i mean why so this
understand what she's doing she's she's
continuing to blow smoke you know and
saying
that memo with like your six or eight
ways to steal the election i thought it
was totally solid and how dare mike
pence not actually go forward didn't he
act on it because you gave him the legal
reasoning to do that i know i know now
it's and now in a piece in the atlantic
two days ago
they're already anticipating trump
winning in 2024
and they're using my arguments from that
memo that they all said had no
credibility to argue that kamala harris
can block trump
i mean it's like
you know it's like i mean come on people
you know basically everyone's gonna say
you're being proven right yeah exactly
exactly except for not saying that right
so first of all the idea that maybe the
memo was sort of like ingest or whatever
he seems to really believe that that was
a way to steal the election but that's
what they mean yeah exactly exactly all
of your legal reasoning is totally solid
yeah yeah there's no question
but i mean like you know just
supported a supporter like why do you
think that mike pence didn't do it well
because mike pence is an establishment
guy at the end of the day how about that
huh trump's legal adviser who came up
with a way to steal the election saying
the reason pence didn't do it is pence's
establishment
pence did pence's two establishment to
really do what needed to be done
all of the establishment republicans in
d.c
fought into this very myopic view
that trump was destroying the republican
party and what trump was doing is
destroying the inside the beltway
republican party and reviving the
republican party in the hinterland right
what they all consider to be you know
deplorable flyover country
and this uprising that trump got ahead
of he didn't create the movement the
movement was there yeah and he saw it
and got ahead of it
but no that's they can't tolerate that
because they all they all have nice
cushy livings inside this guy is a true
believer of this idea that trump was
this
big threat to the establishment and he
was coming in and doing this and doing
that and that's why mike pence and
others uh didn't uh didn't help trump
take the election
if there is uh uh ever a true believer
it's this guy uh we have another clip
here and it's it's just as crazy let's
continue watching do you think if like
trump came down like on the sticks like
it would change things changed a little
bit if he came down yeah he said he was
coming down down to the capitol so
understand the question here is if trump
himself did march to the capitol like he
said he was going to would that have
maybe succeeded in stopping the count
yeah i don't yeah i don't know because
because
the the uh
the breaking of the windows stuff had
already started before his speech was
over
and if he got if he got down there then
all of that would have been blamed on
him i like how he minimizes the
insurrectionist coup
as the breaking of the windows there was
a little more going on than breaking
windows they're still blaming it but
they would have had more bases for it
so
he'd been planning on coming down though
yeah i know i know i know so yeah
look the whole thing was
a setup i mean it was a setup uh john
sullivan
antifa guy got paid 60 000 bucks by cnn
to break in and get video of violence
right this is a fact so again
this guy this is how dangerous these
people are
we didn't necessarily know with this
eastman character
is he a true believer
or
did he get paid to write a memo like
okay yeah here's like a hypothetical
very hypothetical this nobody's really
going to pay attention to this no one's
going to believe this this wouldn't even
really work i don't know i'll just write
it for you because i'm getting paid no
no no no
this undercover video seems to be making
clear this guy is a true believer
he believes the antifa conspiracy
theories
he believes it was actually
legally viable to steal the election the
way he outlined in the map it's
incredible
the oat keepers and the proud boys had
not just kind of
wallflowers sitting on the side of the
organization but people instigating
within the association fbi
uh plans
these were it was a setup so the riots
were antifa and the fbi and you know
unfortunately our guys walk into the
tracks
but so he would have gone down there if
it hadn't been for the violin yeah like
he he decided not to go because people
were
engaging in violence and breaking stuff
yeah because i mean he didn't want that
right no and he and he immediately
tweeted out
what he said on his speech
go down there peacefully and
patriotically and let your voices be
heard right
actually what trump did was even hours
after there had been violent riots for
hours
trump reluctantly did a video where he
says it's time to go home but he
mentioned we love you and you're
completely justified in being here i
know why you're here it was stolen etc
but it's time to go home after just
hours of pressure of people saying trump
sir you got it you got to say something
you got to get these people home there's
a third part to this interview which as
of this moment that we're recording
today's show lauren windsor has not yet
released but i encourage you to take a
look at it when it is incredible stuff
and we'll have more on this on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today david liss who is a health
services researcher at northwestern
university he conducts research to
improve the quality and value of primary
care delivery david it's great having
you on today
thanks for having me so you know in the
context of obamacare but also more
generally there's the discussion of of
preventive health care the idea that
it's cheaper to prevent or treat
something early than it is to wait until
it becomes more serious i think that
intuitively makes sense to to a lot of
people
but that can take sort of a lot of
different forms and shapes one can be
you go into the doctor every year and
they feel around listen to your lungs
etc
that could include doing regular blood
work cholesterol complete blood count
etc
then there's also other types of
screenings starting to do psa and
prostate exams for men at certain ages
colonoscopies
mammograms etc so there's all this
different stuff
how can we start to kind of categorize
these things and think about the impact
on people's people's health from them
well um
i think uh well at least what we do here
in the research world or in the sort of
medical care world is that there's uh
an organization called the u.s
preventive services task force
and uh that's been around for a while
and but what the affordable care act did
is that what it it took services that
are recommended by this group the uspstf
as we call it and services that are
recommended by the by this group are now
fully covered under pretty much all or
certainly most insurance plans that
people have so uh we're talking about
some of the things you mentioned there
things like colonoscopies and colorectal
cancer screening mammography for women
age 50 to 74
recommended vaccinations etc so there
are many services that have been shown
there's clear benefit they can help
people live longer and healthier lives
and there's been this group of
researchers who has really sifted
through the data continues to pour
through it every few years and they find
that these are beneficial services other
things like prostate cancer screening
that i think you may have mentioned psa
tests even these kind of routine lab
tests a lot of those services aren't
actually recommended to be done
regularly maybe for some high risk
patients but for your average or low
risk patients some of those services are
not recommended by this group and aren't
necessarily covered for free through
your insurance plans yeah so
you know there's this idea of uh what is
it that we're trying to do like with a
general health check
and
one answer would be well we're trying to
diagnose
something earlier in order to control it
and then a subsequent question i guess
would be okay if we do that
are we
improving quality of life we're
extending life and and i guess the
answer is not always yes it kind of
depends what we're doing right
it depends yes um but
again there are a lot of kinds of
screenings we can do a lot of kinds of
risk factor checks that can be done
where again if you catch it early and
there are
available well known treatments you can
certainly be extending life and quality
of life now the problem there is that
there if you're doing things that aren't
necessarily recommended um maybe that
again that could fall in the range of
things like psa tests could be things
like routine labs there's a potential
for a lot of these false positives as
you will maybe the test finds something
and it's potentially worrisome and it
leads to this sort of cascade of testing
lots of worry on the part of the patient
additional testing and sometimes all for
no reasons all for sometimes for a false
positive mammography that happens
sometimes so what we what we try to do
sort of in the research world and
medical world is find a balance between
uh whether
as we've heard i think sometimes when we
think about the vaccination debate for
for covin where do the potential
benefits outweigh the potential harms
and again there are several services
certainly colorectal cancer screening
being one where the potential benefits
certainly clearly outweigh the potential
harms one of the things i read and i'd
be interested in hearing what your
research has shown or your take on it is
that a lot of the things that are done
that are kind of in the cardiovascular
under the cardiovascular umbrella
don't seem to actually reduce an
individual's chance of having a heart
attack what is is can you talk about
that a little bit is that true what does
it even mean to say that well what i
what i certainly can say is that uh some
of the bread and butter things we think
about most
most uh stereotypically
checking your blood pressure it
obviously happens that all of our
doctors that's perhaps the most or
certainly one of the most important
things that can happen
in terms of helping people uh identify a
health problem and getting it under
control we've many uh you know highly
effective uh inexpensive treatments that
uh can help prevent heart attacks stroke
death etc some of these other maybe more
exotic kind of tests again
doing a lot of digging
doing a lot of tests that aren't
necessarily recommended again that's
where we're talking about the potential
harm could outweigh the potential
benefit
when we talk about the annual physical
for a second and we have the parts which
are
a discussion where you might mention
symptoms or answer lifestyle questions
and then you have the physical exam
which depending on one's age varies and
then you have here are the blood tests
or other things that i want you to do
everything but the physical exam could
be done virtually what do we know about
the what do we know about the importance
of the part that's happening in person
with the annual physical versus the
other and of course once you're at a
certain age and there's a
you know a prostate check that obviously
cannot be done virtually
so uh you're right a lot of these sort
of elements of these visits could be
done virtually
uh what i would also say is that what
some of our research has shown uh
research research really clearly shows
is that the physical exam some a
comprehensive physical is not necessary
what has been shown to be uh clearly
effective and i think you alluded to
there is we're talking about lots of
screenings
lots of risk factor checks uh and again
as you said a lot of that could be done
virtually could be done even on you know
kind of sometimes be a questionnaire on
your computer things like screening for
depression screening for problem
drinking screening for smoking or
tobacco use
so much of this
these kinds of screenings can be done
virtually um
what were the i think what's interesting
what we'd like to learn is what can be
done really well virtually what are some
good models to do that virtually
certainly there's a lot of work that can
be done but let's say you do find a
patient is depressed now if you've done
that screening virtually how can you
connect with them and get them in to get
recommended care or and or
you know things like blood pressure
screenings if someone's experienced at
it certainly they could be doing it if
they have one of these blood pressure
cuffs that could be
that could be used at home that said
it's not always so simple and i think uh
it'll be really interesting to see what
are the balance what what what can we
clearly find that can be done well
consistently at home or virtually versus
what things need to be done in office
and how do we sort of
get that sort of division of labor
worked out one of the things that seems
like it might make it more difficult to
ascertain sort of health outcomes and
health status might be
that people who
do the annual physicals
maybe folks that are already more likely
to maybe make healthier lifestyle
choices or maybe eat a better diet or or
whatever the case may be
is it possible to separate that out to
really talk about the impact just of the
physical and the the screenings
so there's a i think maybe a couple
things you mentioned there let me uh
again go first go back and say these
physical exams themselves we don't
really need these comprehensive physical
exams but as you touch on as well uh
these visits these checkups as uh i like
to call them uh oftentimes what we find
is the people who are most likely to get
these checkup visits are people who have
gotten them previously made right here
for that group we found um
the the potential benefit isn't as great
as people who might be sort of hyped
from higher risk groups and for those
folks who aren't necessarily as
motivated i would certainly encourage
them to sort of think about getting one
of these checkups but from a from the
perspective of a healthcare system or a
health system
that's where we need to do a little bit
better work in terms of identifying
those patients and finding ways to get
them in finding ways to help them
understand the need to come in and the
benefits
for coming in or if it doesn't involve
coming and doing some sort of a virtual
screening re meeting them where they are
and doing one of these checkups because
that's where our really checkup visits
have we think have the most value people
who haven't necessarily been well
connected with the doctor who might be
overdue for preventive services whether
that's cancer screenings vaccinations
etc
it's often mentioned
that there are people who believe
that the reason that a lot of these
things are suggested etc uh is a desire
from medical practitioners to avoid um
lawsuits to say hey listen i d i did my
part i did everything i'm supposed to do
we're gonna add stuff and the more stuff
we add the more likely it is i can say i
didn't commit malpractice i did
everything i was supposed to do
in your experience how how valid is that
concern or that assertion about the
entire preventive care world
certainly not i would say certainly not
agree with that as it relates to the
entire preventive care world because as
we spoke about a couple minutes ago
when we talk about for what most
insurance plans are going to cover with
zero copay for patients as a result of
the affordable care act we're talking
about these high value recommended
services that have been screened and are
and are reviewed every few years by this
panel of experts
and these are shown to be consistently
high value services now that's
there's that we need to strike that
balance we don't wanna i come out and i
say we want people to come in for
checkups and get some of these
recommended high value services where
it's good is that again they're covered
with zero copay most people are not
going to have to spend a dime to be
getting these services at their checkups
their cancer screenings their
vaccinations screening for depression
etc some of those lower value services
some of the things that people as you
mentioned might be sort of more
skeptical of
uh i think some of those things there is
reasonable skepticism and some of those
things the experts have shown there
isn't good value to those but uh
for the typical checkup covered by your
typical insurance company we're talking
about high value services that have been
shown to be effective and again aren't
going to cost people money to be
receiving them related to this and i
don't know if you can say anything about
this at all and if not that's fine when
we talk about the dental cleaning and
now we're talking about dental health
number one there's research into the
connection between dental health and
general health which seems to be pretty
compelling and number two
it seems that in that case we're really
talking about something with very
specific benefits it where in all of
this does the dental cleaning every six
months and with or without x-rays which
i know is a big uh source of controversy
for some
yeah i um i don't have much expertise
there so uh and my research doesn't
really focus on dental cleaning that
much but as you said i've heard that
there's a lot of research showing that
dental cleanings are associated i
believe with good kind of cardiovascular
and heart health outcomes which is quite
interesting probably relates to some
issues as
as it deals with things like
inflammation in the body right um but
also maybe it speaks to the fact a
little bit of how sort of siloed
sometimes healthcare is in the united
states and that a lot of us you know
health health insurance coverage is
separate from dental coverage and uh
those aren't maybe necessarily as sort
of harmonized or as um
comprehensive as they should be on the
in the dental care area but again
regular checkups sounds like i know is a
is something that is recommended for
dental care and certain and has been
shown to be associated with good overall
health outcomes uh very very interesting
we've been speaking with david liss
who's a health services researcher at
northwestern university he conducts
research to improve the quality and
value of primary care delivery really
appreciate your time and sharing your
insights david
thank you pleasure
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show all right
let's jump into the paternity leave
debate now i i
to even get into this i think it's
important to mention
that the recent hubbub about secretary
of transportation pete buddha judge's
paternity leave
it's not even necessarily about
paternity leave there's a homophobic
aspect of this which is the feminization
of a gay man like pete budege taking
paternity leave which really should be
for moms it's really for women has he
been learning how to breastfeed tucker
carlson said feminizing a gay man so
there's like there's a homophobic aspect
to it that's that's one piece of it
there's another piece of it which for
some people it's just political
opportunism which is
under trump
the republicans weren't blaming trump
for the supply shortages that we had
early during the pandemic
under trump republicans weren't blaming
trump's secretary of transportation
elaine chao
now those very same republicans are
blaming joe biden
and blaming pete buddha judge so for
some it's political opportunism but then
there's also an aspect of this which
kind of feels more psychological either
like a my dad wasn't around when i was
little so there should nobody should get
paternity leave kind of like a if i
can't play in the sandbox i'm gonna poop
in it and shut the whole thing down
um or also kind of a um
antiquated tropes of uh it being
feminine
to
take time off when you've had a kid
right so there's a lot of different
motivations for different people
the latest is joe rogan uh weighing in
on this during an interview he did with
a bridget bridget fedesy fatassi i'm not
exactly sure how her last name is
pronounced i believe she's a comedian
um and again they get into this issue of
pete buddha judges paternity leave uh
let's take a listen and then we'll we'll
discuss
what's crazy is that pete buddha judge
during this whole time is on paternity
leave
so what they mean is during the supply
shortages that we're having this entire
time pete buddha judges on paternity
leave i want to go listen man i
understand it's hard to raise a child
but um isn't that supposed to be for the
person who gave birth
it's crazy yeah
now over 70 ships containing 500 000
containers are waiting off shore 500
pounds but he was saying now
those ships pete bootage edge doesn't
control those ships p buddha judge is
one guy a country of 330 million people
even if you believe that it's the
department of transportation that
controls those ships there's a deputy
secretary of transportation and an
undersecretary of transportation the
idea that it's because pete is holding a
baby
instead of a phone even though he's
actually been participating in in
meetings anyway
the ships are stuck it's it's such a
silly childish idea it's like this
negative feedback loop that is rapidly
cycling out of control that if it
continues on a beta will destroy the
global economy
i'm like that's a nice one to just slide
in there okay
yeah
um so it's complicated but i do know the
trucking stuff has something to do with
it too because there was already
problems with truckers they kind of
abandoned california that's what it
looked like two years ago this is a
visualization of like the data they used
so we're watching trucks this is a
couple of couple ships just a couple
ships this is 2019. since last week
why are there so many
because they're all i mean this is why
oh that's why yeah because they're stuck
yeah they're all floating around out
here waiting to find space to come into
there to go wait and they can kind of
get in there like you said if there's
only seven out of hundreds of cranes
emptying them then they're waiting
it's nuts
it's nuts and that's why you can't buy
toys and it's also affecting small
businesses yeah you know okay so the
point here is they're blaming
pete buddha judge for this and isn't it
women that are supposed to take leave
when there's a kid born not the men now
interestingly spotify
for which you know joe rogan now
licenses his show works for spotify you
use whatever term you want
uh they give six months of leave
regardless of gender
uh which is which is interesting uh the
other thing about this actually let's
look at let's look at one more clip
because i have some other thoughts but
they're relevant to this next part i'm
and i'm questioning what who do you
believe
should pay for something like i don't
know but if i was an employer
and i had a guy who worked for me i had
a guy who worked for me he wanted to
take three months off because his wife
gave birth i'd be like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about mike
even to support his wife give birth to
support his wife will i pay him for free
do you understand that this is kind of
most people when this happens
if they make enough money the wife will
not work and the father will work right
now
that might be plausible
if the man makes more money
i have friends where
the wife
is a doctor and makes more money i have
friends where the wife is a lawyer and
makes more money and it really doesn't
make sense what joe rogan is actually
saying
um and so even that already is based on
a whole this is just basically
it's a suicide when you assume
you got you guys know the thing okay all
right okay and then the wife takes care
of the child
and this is normal yeah and then normal
what does that mean these are such
loaded terms and unfortunately this was
not you know i think if someone else was
speaking to joe rogan about this he you
could say what do you mean normal do you
mean it's historically typical
based on
something that started during an era
where often women didn't work at all and
were less educated than men which has
been completely reversed at this point
you know it's it's this very kind of
like
1950s
thinking that's not really relevant
today the dad provides support when he
comes home if you're saying that the man
and the woman should both get like three
months off this is a new thing yeah
right new isn't bad now like that's also
fallacious
continuing to do something the way it
used to be done
is not an argument the fact that it used
to be a different way is not actually an
argument it's not new in europe but
we're not in europe
this is better
okay and so then then we add in this
idea of
in europe the men are feminized they're
[ __ ] men here in the united states
we're manly so it's like they're hitting
all the different tropes here now i want
to introduce a different
kind of question into this
you know there's this movement um
they're called men's rights activists
now there are people who believe some of
the things men rights activists believe
and they're not actually men's rights
activists i think it's important to say
they just kind of
gravitate towards the ideology in some
areas but there's this whole movement
which is about complaining women get
preferential treatment on everything in
the united states men get the shaft when
it comes to
divorce
men get the shaft and women get
preferential treatment when it comes to
police interactions around domestic
violence
women get preferential treatment and men
get the shot you know all this different
stuff
you would think that they would be
saying hey you know what this is great
women have gotten the preferential
treatment on maternity leave at all or
paid maternity leave now
we're equalizing it the men aren't going
to get the shaft anymore
but that's not the perspective of many
of those very same people so just it's
all stereotypical tropes the europeans
as the [ __ ] girly men real men don't
need time off in the u.s
i'm going to go to work and then i'll
come home and then i'll hold the baby or
whatever it's just very antiquated stuff
and then the other thing again the
context of blaming p buddha judge
country of 330 million people the idea
that everything depends on one guy who's
home with his kids these issues started
under trump no one blamed transportation
secretary under trump elaine chao it's
pathetic
last possible angle
is it possible that there are people
that are worked up about this
whose dads weren't around when they were
kids their dads didn't have any
paternity leave never mind paid
paternity leave
and they're transferring that into the
same type of thing we're seeing with
student loans listen i had to pay my
student loans so we shouldn't forgive
them for anybody listen my dad wasn't
around when i was a kid so there
shouldn't be paternity leave now is
there maybe that psychological element
that's affecting some people's view on
this as well i'm not talking about joe
rogan i have no idea his family history
these are general questions that i have
i'd be curious to hear your thoughts
there's been a headline floating around
over the last 24 hours
that republican senator ted cruz
defended
giving nazi salutes at school board
meetings now that's not true i'm going
to tell you right now
that is not
actually what ted cruz did what ted cruz
did is is horrible and i'm going to play
it for you but it would not be accurate
that ted cruz
defends nazi salutes what ted cruz did
defend
is
the fact that
parents doing nazi salutes at school
board meetings
is protected by the first amendment now
i think it was still very stupid to do
um and it also
is theoretically something which could
lead to an investigation depending on
circumstances but that's actually kind
of a second or third layer so let's talk
about what's going on the daily beast
headline is ted cruz defends parents
doing nazi salutes at school board
meetings
maybe yeah i mean he he certainly
doesn't defend the salute okay um
during a fiery senate judiciary
committee on wednesday hearing on
wednesday ted cruz at one point defended
parents throwing up nazi salutes at
school school board meetings as
protected by the first amendment okay
cruz along with other republicans
lambasted attorney general merrick
garland for directing the justice
department to investigate the rise in
violent threats against educators now
remember
the national school board association is
the organization that asked that the
school board protests at least be
considered under the guise of domestic
terrorism that was not what the
department of justice fbi or merrick
garland asked they were asked to do that
and that's really really important so
we're going to play the clip
and
we'll talk about the implications and
and different things here so but listen
very carefully to the language that's
being used i did a quick count just
sitting here during this hearing i
counted 20 incidents cited
of the 20
15 on their face are non-violent
they involve things like insults they
involve a nazi salute that's one of the
examples my god a parent did a nazi
salute at a school board because he
thought the the policies were oppressive
general garland is doing a nazi salute
and elected official is that protected
by the first amendment yes it is
okay
so
i think we should be careful with our
language and so all the headlines saying
ted cruz defends or supports nazi
salutes
he's doing something horrible in this
clip but he's not actually doing that
what ted cruz is saying
is first of all a nazi salute is speech
protected by the first amendment that's
true
now the first amendment doesn't insulate
you
from the repercussions to that speech so
cruz is correct saying that
a nazi salute is protected speech and
garland agreed that's not actually the
controversy that's a fake part of the
controversy no one is saying a nazi
salute is not protected by the first
amendment
but cruz is using all of this to go to
this idea
that merrick garland told the department
of justice to investigate parents doing
nazi salutes as domestic terrorists
that's number one not true
and number two it's a red herring
merrick garland
correctly explains later in this hearing
the national school board association
wrote us a memo
saying consider whether some of these
actions at school board meetings by
parents are domestic terrorism that's
what the national school board
association asked to have happen
it was not something merrick garland
directed but let's go to the next and
maybe more interesting thing
just because something is protected
speech
doesn't mean it can't be grounds for an
investigation
it's you know imagine that i say
at a school board meeting
um i've got a dead body in my basement
okay just to come up with something
and then i leave
my
what i said is i guess protected by the
first amendment in other words a
state-run school
i'm allowed to speak the school can't
censor me whatever
but
you could still then hear what i said
and say oh wow
we've got to now investigate you because
of the content of what you said
i was able to speak my ability to speak
was not curtailed by the school which i
guess you could say is state government
but
what i said can still have consequences
and uh along the same lines
without getting into the specifics of a
nazi salute or whatever
the things that parents say at school
board meetings could be used as the
basis for investigations whether it's
investigations into domestic terrorism
whether apparent in talking about
you know i'm against masks like i slap
my kid around at home when they do
something wrong but i'm not going to put
a mask on well protected services could
hear that and say okay you were allowed
to say your piece but we now are going
to use the content of what you said to
launch an investigation because you're
saying you're smacking your kid around
so these are like two three four
different issues the lessons here are
maybe not good to use nazi salutes of
examples of things that should be
defended it no matter what you know
maybe ted cruz can pick other examples
and make sure to look at the video
because really i think it's an
exaggeration to say ted cruz defended
the salute he was trying to make a point
about its protection under the first
amendment about which he is right
and then he goes into all sorts of other
things that don't make sense let me know
your thoughts about the segment we have
a voicemail number that number is 2192
david p here's a conspiracy theory that
uh the alec baldwin shooting was a false
flag meant to cause to confiscate guns
hey david is troll man the
anti-intellectual
it's sad what happened with alec baldwin
the part that isn't being said is that
that gun was planted with a real
bullet
planted so that very conspiratorial
language the left has an excuse
and a reason to say see we need to take
reins on the guns we need to regulate we
need to disarm the population of these
guns
why don't you mention that in your
discussion because there is absolutely
no evidence to suggest that this is the
exact same argument that some made about
the sandy hook school shooting when
barack obama was president it was staged
in order to have a big national tragedy
to then subsequently try to confiscate
guns what's pathetic is even after the
sandy hook shooting we couldn't even get
universal background checks passed never
mind confiscating any guns and the
reason i haven't mentioned it troll man
is that there is no reason whatsoever to
believe that that's what took place
we've got a great bonus show for you
today don't let this stuff rot your
brain sign up at jointpakman.com we will
see you on the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helix sleep dot com slash pacman